[Music]
good morning how's everybody doing today
awesome so we have a full talk today
it's it's very packed we're gonna cover
some very interesting topics so I'm Alan
aim I work on Google kubernetes engine
at Google I'm part of the product
management team there and I am joined
today by Wei Tang who is VP of product
at stack rocks so stack rocks provides
container security it is one of the
options that's available when you're
running google kubernetes engine and
we're also joined by Alex van box'll who
is a cloud architect at venti exclusive
and then Connor Gilbert but stack rocks
will actually be wrapping up our talk
today with a really really cool demo so
really looking forward to that so let me
let me frame the conversation before we
dive into things the talk is called gke
architecture patterns for retail and
financial services and I bet you're
asking why retail why financial services
what is a similarity here why are we
talking about these two industries
together and the reason for that is from
an executive priority standpoint there
are similarities in terms of what these
two industries are really trying to
achieve although from a regulatory
standpoint it's very different right in
terms of challenges that you face from a
financial services standpoint versus
retail from an executive priority
standpoint some of the commonalities
include you know your data is your most
important asset right in both industries
and and the two industries are really
transforming as well right retailers
whether it's brick-and-mortar or
e-commerce are becoming software
companies in many ways right the need to
be able to deliver software quickly and
push that software to the edges and
transform that customer experience in
real time is crucial is really crucial
to competing in both industries are
really in the midst of this
you know with the advent of open source
technologies in particular
containerization from several years ago
right it's it's presented a way for
companies within these verticals to
really be an internet scale company and
figure out ways to really bring the
experience to the user as efficiently
and quickly as possible and that's all a
lot of it is software how do you build
that software to enable that and make
that happen right our customers are
becoming smarter and smarter right there
are so many signals associated with
customers that you need to keep track of
and and and be aware of in terms of
tailoring that experience for your
customers at the same time you know this
is a study that was done very recently
seventy-five percent of customers out
there expect a consistent experience in
terms of dealing with the institution's
right whether it's mobile whether it's
online whether it's going in to the
brick-and-mortar location or a banking a
banking center at the same time sixty
four percent of consumers expect that
organizations will respond and interact
with them in real time we live in a
society where people really have no
patience you want response immediately
and you want that response to be
continuous and then two-thirds of
consumers will actually switch brands if
they're treated as numbers instead of
individuals so you have to tailor that
experience for that customer and how do
you do that again using software so just
a show of hands how many people here are
actually running containers and
production very cool how about using
kubernetes and using kubernetes on
google cloud kubernetes engine it's
fantastic and then how many developers
here okay great this is a great
composition so the technology impact is
really transforming how people do things
today and a lot of it has really been
being pushed by containers
by efficiencies around continuous
integration and continuous delivery as
well as machine learning that's really
bringing a facet in terms of how you
make decisions and bringing the cloud
into a lot of this workflow and for
companies that are really at the midst
of this today and in particular I'm
seeing this a lot with retail and
financial services there's only two ways
that you can go right at the end of the
day we all want to get to that top right
corner but you know it's either up or
out and and really the up path is taking
what you have today in your data centers
and modernizing it right most a lot of
companies that I talk to you're actually
building passes on top of their existing
infrastructure because they want that
speed that agility on the other hand you
can move to the cloud lift and shift and
then modernize when you're in the cloud
so we see both of these trends that are
happening but eventually we all want to
get to that top right quadrant and
there's always going to be component
that's sitting whether it's on-premises
or multi cloud but you want to be able
to manage these investments in a
consistent fashion
so from an internet scale application
architecture at the end of the day you
know we all want to be able to push
releases you know n number of times each
night we want to be able to build
applications that are coherent we
resilient and scale really well without
having to worry about the underlying
infrastructure but as a developer all
you really want to care about is your
application right you you really don't
want to care about the underlying
mechanisms like your networking your
load balance your your health checks how
you implement that resilient
architecture of course it's important
but you really want to focus on the
application and then let the underlying
framework really do a lot of the heavy
lifting to abstract away the
complexities for that application
underneath that application and really
that's where kubernetes came in to the
picture
you know container solve a very
important
problem right in terms of how do you
package up an application make it
portable run it in such a way where
you're taking all these various
dependencies and you have a really
predictable way of running that
application across different
environments but then it introduces a
lot of complexities such as how do you
scale these applications how do you run
you know these containers across a pool
of compute containers are ephemeral how
do you map storage to these containers
and ensure that you can run not just 12
factors stateless applications but
stateful applications as well how do you
do that in a consistent fashion
what about de to type models around
operations monitoring logging how do you
expose containers to the outside world
so that they can be consumed by external
applications those are the kinds of
things that kubernetes really helps
solve and Google has had a managed
kubernetes offering for the last three
years it went GA general availability
three years ago called google kubernetes
engine which is a managed service around
kubernetes that basically makes the
cluster creation process an API call you
specify how many nodes you want where
you want your nodes to live the type of
resiliency and highly available
infrastructure that you want underneath
your cluster and then you're you're in
business you've got an API a
command-line interface that you can now
use to deploy and run your applications
so what I wanted to do now is you know I
can sit here and talk and explain all
the various great things about Google
kubernetes engine and and kubernetes and
so forth but but I feel like it would be
tremendously more valuable for you to
hear it directly from our customers and
our partners so first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to invite Alex to come
and talk about how Google kubernetes
engine actually enabled them to become
more agile and move to a micro service
architecture and and all of the
challenges that they faced going down
that journey and then we're going to
have Wei bring a different perspective
as a technology partner
they offer a solution that actually
helps customers really build secure
environments I mentioned the important
thing is ensuring your data is safe well
ways gonna bring a different perspective
around like what are some of the
patterns that you should be implementing
to ensure that your environment
container environment is protected and
secured and then we'll show you demo or
on that so without any further ado Alex
the floor is yours
Thank You Alan
so I'm Alex I'm a cloud architect so in
a company at that our country and size
that means you also have to get your
hands dirty and you also code so Butlins
me a first president font exclusive not
like it's it's French name so it's font
exclusive for Texas is in a special kind
of e-commerce business and it's the
flash sales what what does that mean
it's like we have like every day like a
hundred sales open and they close each
day we have like opening and closing
sales on average a sale is open for
around a week and so as soon as that
sale closes the goods are ordered with
the suppliers and shifts to our
customers so it's not the next day
delivery in general so about two years
ago we've been acquired by a bigger
company and that acquisition actually
brought some special things we we could
like operate the northern of Europe it's
like it was a French company that
acquired this so that means everything
both France and that acquisition so
brought some like special case for us
because we were normally operating in a
small part of Europe and we're running a
monolith and going to the northern of
Europe that means like more countries
with special business needs more
languages and other currencies not all
of Europe is running the you
so with that we said we're gonna develop
the platform of the future and go for
micro services running a monolid for ten
years brought some extra advantages we
actually knew our business quite well so
we put silos in our architecture that
was like this shop the warehouse data
and within those silos everybody could
make their micro services on a certain
use case or domain the technology that
could use be used there could be really
tailored to the use case or the
competence of the team as we were quite
mainly a dotnet company most of our
services where we are created in dotnet
but like in the data team with data
scientists button is more in their skill
sets so there it turned out that we are
like a lot of byte encodes and even go
if we really needed to have performance
the databases it was also the choice of
the best use case so it could be a
relational or non-relational it didn't
matter they had their own choice but a
very important thing is that each micro
service has like very data is data
separated so very good isolation between
them and at a time so we started like
more than a year ago to fitori
platforming and why did we pick
kubernetes well because at the time that
we chose till then tolki Benitez came
along and docker came along
containerized thinks containerization
was really a technical thing and
cabinets were the first Orchestrator
that actually brought some concepts that
a human could understand and luckily we
were already on Google with a data
platform so we actually tried at GK we
also Pro
asked for an offer
other current hosting provider but by
the time the day came with with a real
offer
we were already running some stuff on JK
but going to micro-service brings some
extra challenges so it's more than three
but I picked three of my favorite ones
it's like the developer experience
observer ability and also the data style
data silos developer experience so if
you used to creating a model it and then
have to go to make very big blocks you
have to make sure that developers don't
lose speed so in the beginning we did a
lot of small things and make sure that
the developers didn't go the
developments we didn't go too low so the
first thing was like access control
luckily who left like the Google
accounts that we really could could sync
with our on-premise Active Directory and
it was with just a snap DF access to the
cluster and with Google accounts they
also have like access to services like
logging tracing and even if they needed
bigquery you could have access to
bigquery another thing that is very
important was very important and helped
us really in the beginning was make sure
that you have a set of guidelines
between the teams it's very important
one of them is like make sure that your
microphone aims like poor porting or is
it back office reporting but the thing
is that it really helps with automating
the process so it like conventions when
there was API at the back then we
automatically exposed that to the
outside world
was it the batch - no it was a batch
system it really helps to just make the
developer flow go well
another thing is make sure that you have
contracts defined between a
microservices weeks only learned the
hard way that going good first is not
the best approach
so we actually slowly moving now to a
contract first where we are slowly
moving to G RPC and with some cool tools
like Cloud endpoints and probably is to
you as well it it eases the way because
it can expose your G RPC interfaces as
the rest as well then don't forget this
continuous deployment start in the
beginning all those conventions and so
on really help automate the process
automation processes but make sure that
it was automation processes are all
centered around the continuous
deployment pipeline we choice hit lock
because it is a nice combination with
git repos and deployment pipelines and
it has nice tools for code reviews as
well we are now going to the next level
and with the evolution of cuban natives
with custom resource definitions we are
going for a geat approach he tops
approach where everything the desired
state is in heat itself next
observability as everything is like
scattered around make sure that your
system is observed below like in a
single application it's a bit simpler
but luckily Google has a stackdriver
suit it probably saw it yesterday that
there were some nice announcements here
but so that's that's very good so every
micro service for us we had like the
Cloud endpoints but now it sto globally
you enter code to e steel but we have
been running this for a year in Cloud
endpoints really helped us to make it
observable but have it because having
actually
proxy's just in front of your
microservice make sure that everything
is locked and traced that really helps
those locks and so our aggregated with
everything in the Google ecosystem so
everything what comes in the network and
even your cabinet is clustered all come
together in the same logging system and
it really helps Dively dive deep deep
but don't forget make sure that you have
like special log entry points trace
points and metrics as well in your
application because an example of a
metric is like active cars for example
and through this stack drivers suit it's
all merges to the operational loss at
your custom metrics together to have a
deep dive and if you want to be an
observer an observer superstar make sure
to export all your last loss to bigquery
and quite find it quite strange that not
a lot of people do that but it's just a
click away and now now it's the time to
go to do eesti oh look at that one we
work on Cloud endpoints because we
started very early make sure to look at
ISTE oh and also make sure to look at
open census with that you get like nice
dashboards now it's an answer for
yesterday you also have service graphs
added on top of it and that's very
important if you want to dig deep if you
have a troubling intervals in your
system and the last but this is my
favorite one is how to get the flow of
your data in your system so everybody
knows the typical use case of sinkholes
where microservice a cos B and B and C
but make sure to go for an I think
approach as well where you actually put
everything on pops up pops up is also
good technology of Google where it just
can publish your entities and that makes
it possible for
microservices to subscribe that an
example is when a cart is complete you
logistic process could listen on those
events and trigger the slow flows and
with the added value if you do it
consistently over all our micro
microservices you could listen that in
your data lake and all those topics and
and combine everything into bigquery
BigTable or elastic or whatever
technology you choose and that's a way
where you actually break the barriers
between between those silos and then
your data analysts your marketeers
really have one to two query over
everything and then slanders then
bigquery and it combines you have some
nice dashboarding tools like tableau
where you can have back a view on the
business so in hindsight going to cuba
netezza engine was really a lifesaver
because then we could focus on those
problems but because like having a
managed surface service is not just
trying to be netizen a few few VMS no it
brings out a scaler
how to repair monitoring all out of the
box and we did three monthly release
cycle of kubernetes the newest version
of kubernetes just a click away like I
do an upgrade of the cluster do a new
version in a meeting so lessons learned
make sure to have like conventions
contracts and automation in place that
will help you accelerate your developers
if you don't have those things you you
could be up for some here cows and
embrace an eventual consistently
consistency through pops up but it
published every entity in that and
listen they're in your data Lake and put
it in bigquery and make your system
observable certainly with a nice to
announce yesterday so we this will be
great
so that's it for me right it's up to you
thank you name is Whaley and dang
I am VP of product at stack rocks stack
rocks is a Bay Area based startup that
delivers cloud native security for the
global 2000 our product is a platform
that secures containers and micro
services across their entire lifecycle
from build to runtime we're pleased to
be a Google cloud partner and jointly
working with some of the world's most
recognizable enterprises across
technology media government and
financial services this morning I'll
share about our collaboration with
financial organizations a collaboration
that has enabled them to modernize their
infrastructure and app architectures a
top chrome rating gke and one of the
primary challenges that these customers
face when moving to gke is thinking
through how to effectively leverage a
shared security model which requires
considering what controls do you need to
implement on a standalone basis versus
where do you need to augment existing
controls that are provided by gke and
our customers tend to hone in on the
following concerns the first is can
strong security boundaries be
established to isolate and segregate
containerized workloads isolation needs
to extend across pods and services nodes
and clusters and so on second what is
needed to ensure that the container
software supply chain which generates
the images used to instantiate
containers remains under the customers
control you need continuous verification
at a station and auditability and
finally this customer segment has to
tackle regulatory compliance in a
context where requirements for
containers specifically are not yet that
well defined and so relevant
certifications and data protection
requirements are going to vary across
workloads of course but what we tend to
see is that financial cost
take conservative interpretations of
existing requirements map them to
container environments and also
increasingly adhere to guidance on
container security that has been
published by organizations such as NIST
and the Center for Internet Security I'm
excited this morning to share three
examples of how the combination of gke
and stack rocks together has
successfully enabled enterprises to
navigate these concerns in the first
example we've worked with a fortune 100
Bank that Bank has a line of business
that's leading the banks digital
transformation efforts to reimagine the
consumer experience and to do that
they've built an entirely new investment
management application that runs on
hundreds of nodes in gke in the second
example
14:50 financial services firm runs
containerized analytic services on
dozens of nodes in g ke on-demand to
better leverage data that has already
been warehoused in GCP thereby driving
greater are alive and in the third
example a global 200 enterprise has
really tected its sass ecommerce
platform a platform that serves small
and medium sized businesses by providing
them with everything from a storefront
to billing and order processing
functions
they've we are connected that platform
atop kubernetes they run it on premises
today with a plan to move it into a
Google cloud and it's designed to scale
to thousands of nodes across dozens of
clusters now Alex talked a lot about
infrastructure modernization and so you
know at the same time these businesses
selected gke and kubernetes to drive
that modernization they also had to
figure out how to address the unique
security challenges that were introduced
by containers existing security tools
lack container awareness and are
rendered obsolete the attack surface
expands beyond just containers
themselves to encompass layers that
include the container runtime the
orchestrator namely kubernetes the
registry and so on and so there's the
emergence of new
vectors that need to be protected
against and then finally the short
ephemeral lifetimes of containers make
necessary functions such as auditing
response and forensics in particularly
much much harder and so to solve these
challenges requires modernizing security
as well and there are lot of great talks
going on this week about security for
kubernetes and gke I encourage you to
check out those talks what stands out is
how kubernetes is modernizing security
with the breadth of baseline
capabilities that are being built into
the platform itself
there's firewalling for pods and
services there's TLS throughout the
cluster there's access control and audit
logging and secrets management and
storage on the master gke takes all of
this operationalizes it for you and
augments it by giving you a minimal
container optimized operating system by
managing the master for you and also
integrating with container analysis and
image scanning functionality that's part
of Google container registry and so
we're a customer previously had to turn
to several standalone security tools to
implement all these controls they can
now benefit from a single infrastructure
platform that makes security fully
programmable but our customers
particularly those in financial space
still require more the move to
containers does not obviate the need for
security functions like vulnerability
management configuration monitoring
compliance policy enforcement threat
detection and instant response these
customers look to standalone solutions
like stack rocks to solve for these use
cases and so what stack rocks does is
unify these sets this set of
capabilities into a single platform that
allows our customers to run on gke with
high assurance and confidence I'm not
going to run through some of the common
architectural patterns that we've seen
among our customer financial customers
adopting gke and so in the first example
that fortune 100 Bank chose to build a
new cloud native mobile first
application on top of gke and what that
looks like is there's a highly scalable
web tier made up of micro services that
sits behind a GCP load balancer and a
reverse proxy
there's a separate set of micro services
that interface it that handles brokerage
functions order order processing
reconciliation and other tasks and that
tier interfaces directly with data that
is persisted off cluster and is non
containerized everything that runs
within the cluster is stateless the tier
also interfaces with a set of internal
custodial services as well as third
party API s and one particular concern
of this customer was that an attacker
could potentially gain a foothold
somewhere in the web tier and then
subsequently move laterally from one
service to another to gain access to the
brokerage tier which would then give it
access and give that person access to
the data or other non containerized bank
services and so the ability to detect
and respond to that type of threat
vector is one of the main use cases that
stack rocks has helped solve for that
customer in the second example that
fortune 50 financial services firm has
already been using bigquery and cloud
dataflow to set up a highly efficient
data pipeline that handles
transformation batch processing and
warehousing and what they've added on is
AG key environment that allows their
developers to spin up containerized
SPARC applications and that those SPARC
applications can be used to process the
data that's already in bigquery or
analyze it or acquire it and manipulate
it and you know gke makes bigquery
integration extremely easy
literally via a drop-down selection in
the console and because those SPARC
services run on demand for limited
periods of time understanding what is
running what has already run and how
policies are enforced on services that
are processing different data sets with
varying degrees of sensitivity becomes a
very hard challenge and so that is one
of the main areas that stack rocks has
helped solve for them as well and then
finally that global 200 Business that
has containerized is existing ecommerce
platform on-premises this is really an
effort designed to drive application
portability and agility and as part of a
plan to eventually
move to Google cloud in gke as part of a
broader lift and shift migration now
what stands out here is that these are
not micro services these are legacy
services think Tomcat think WebLogic
these are not stripped-down services
built from minimal base OS images and so
vulnerability management and
configuration handling misconfigurations
and compliance become critical use cases
that the customer enough initially
focused on separate services are run to
handle logging and monitoring these are
off cluster these are non containerized
but as part of the organization's move
to gke they anticipate adopting sack the
sack diversity which Alex describe for
those functions as a proud partner of
Google cloud we've invested in
delivering a seamless experience across
stack rocks and gke we have a native
integration that automatically sends
alert information out to cloud security
command center so that you can view
threat information about your containers
alongside all of your other security
data about all your other cloud
resources and also reinforced eyes for a
moment the importance and significance
of discovery and gaining visibility when
migrating to gke it is the starting
point for nearly all of the customer
financial customers that we engage with
being able to understand what is running
what has run and to do so in a context
that abstracts away potentially
thousands and thousands of containers
security operators do not want to
immediately know what is going on with
each and every single container rather
than need to be made aware of whether
there's been a particular incident or
threat on a given application and one of
the unique ways that we provide
comprehensive visibility for customers
is we interface with every key layer of
the full container stack and so we
interface with the operating system the
runtime the orchestrator the registry
and so on so that we help build a bigger
picture and deeper picture of how your
gke environment is changing over time so
what have we gleaned from the past
several years of working with the
financial services commune
here are some common practices that we
see nearly all adhere to the first is
they start with hardening their cluster
infrastructure utilizing controls that
are built into kubernetes and gke such
as our role based access control node
constrained service account privileges
network policies metadata concealment
and so on it's very long list which
speaks the richest set of security
capabilities are being built into the
platform itself next they focus on
ensuring that their images are securely
built and secure to use that they meet
best practices and that the runtime
environment is configured against known
batch benchmarks automation is key here
automation and programmability there's
the same principles that are driving
infrastructure modernization also have
to extend to security and finally they
then focus on analyzing container
activity once your containers are
running you can actually analyze their
behavior to better identify threats
because the declarative and immutable
attributes of containers make it easier
to spot when an attacker is potentially
looking to gain a foothold escalate
privileges persists within the
environment move laterally across
services or achieve some type of
objectives such as crypto mining or
exfiltrating data and regardless of
where your organization is on its
container or journey here a set of key
lessons from our customer success
stories that you can act on today the
first is that the security controls that
are built into kubernetes and gke
provide the starting point for any
comprehensive security program identify
what else is needed where to then solve
for additional use cases such as threat
detection and response build in
automation and apply automation fast
iteration and closer collaboration
between security and devops teams as
part of your organizational workflows to
better prevent detect and respond to
threats and then finally tune your
security policies based on the rich
context about containers that can be
gathered via declarative metadata and
runtime configuration collectively these
lessons have helped our customers and
can also help you to
better harness all the advantages that
kubernetes and gke have to offer we're
now excited to show you how this all
comes together like to invite Connor on
stage and he's going to demo and walk
you through three examples of how gke
and stack rocks together help protect
against a set of threats in a live gke
environment I'm Connor I'm excited to
show you a live GK cluster as we
mentioned and demo three real-world
scenarios of container security I could
talk to you about this for hours
especially about how much container
technologies kubernetes and the
integrations with Google products can
really help you get all the right
visibility in the right places but I
have about five minutes so I'm gonna
dive right in
okay so I'm going to show you these
three scenarios there based on exposures
at Tesla Shopify and inspired by the
Equifax attack I don't think they were
using JK so on the screen you've got a
stack Rox portal running in the left
hand side and the terminal that I'll be
using on the right so let's start with
the Tesla example so this is an example
where there was an operational mistake
or a customer's configuration and it led
to a crypto jackin attack discovered by
a security firm who was just scanning
the internet for kubernetes dashboards
so first we're gonna expose the
dashboard here there's communities
dashboard service is is it can be
helpful for debugging but it can be a
security exposure it doesn't run with a
public key trusted cert so I'm just
gonna click through and you can see you
can login with a coop config or a token
if you're going to use your privileges
and just in proxy to the API but you can
also skip and if you do skip it's going
to use the default service account that
the dashboard service is running under
you can see there all these errors you
were trying to debug something and now
your screen is just full of errors
you're supposed to be fixing these not
getting more so you google this you find
out okay this user account cannot list
persistent volume claims and you'll find
some of the Emal's and some instructions
about how to give that service account
cluster admin access and this is
actually I believe what happened
in that Tesla example so I'll go ahead
and elevate permissions for that
dashboard service account and if i
refresh the page I can see everything I
can do bug my problem and then I go away
and I forget to take it off so now
anyone who goes to this node port
address will be able to come in and use
this helpful create button that is up in
the right-hand corner where I can create
deployments so I'm gonna just go ahead
and create a llamo create a deployment
it is running crypto mining service and
upload and there we go
I'm gonna head back to the dashboard and
show you that we will have detected a
new service coming up and then the
crypto minor being run we talked about
you know software supply chain and
what's in your images and everything but
sometimes you do need to know what is
actually happening because I just
introduced an image from a publicly
available registry that wasn't the one
that you were using so you wouldn't have
any sort of scan data or anything you
can see there's a error I'm running
minority inside that process all the
metadata that you'd need to go respond
to that issue okay so now I'm going to
continue on the countermeasure here it's
really like don't do this it's easy to
make these mistakes and the defaults are
getting better but you might have an old
cluster and it's really important to
audit who has cluster admin and the
exposure of the important service is
especially out of that coop system
namespace you can even disable the
dashboard entirely in recent gke
releases alright we'll move on to
Shopify now so I just first want to give
credit to Shopify for helping educate
the community about this kind of issue
they posted this as a bug bounty on
hacker 1 and made a publicly accessible
so that everyone can learn from what
happened to them so let's move on to
that that demonstration the
vulnerability there was if they had a
service that was vulnerable to server
side request forgery
you could ask it to make Network
requests and those network requests
could include internal resources and
sensitive things like the cloud provider
metadata server that's running on every
node so I'm going to start by just
deploying an application that's sort of
true believe own herbal to server side
request forgery and the first thing I'll
do is have it
just check what IP it's running on so
you can see first I'll show my laptop IP
and then then we should be able to see
the IP that the container cluster is
actually running under so there's my
laptop and then this is actually the
container node that the container is
giving egress from on so you can tell
they're different all right so then
that's not super interesting but what is
is starting to use the orchestrator
against itself so you can if you make
this kind of request you can talk to
like the local couplet read-only API and
enumerate things about the cluster that
you're in so for instance I've just gone
in and numerated the images that are
running on this machine and this
actually highlights the importance of
segmentation and separating sensitive
workloads that was mentioned earlier you
can use built-in criminales features
that are fully available on gke to make
separate node pools for sensitive data
applied taints and toleration x' so you
taint a note and then tolerate it in the
workload and you can say that only
sensitive things can schedule on these
sets of nodes so that nothing like my
dumb little app can be scheduled next to
your sensitive data and then be used to
steal it and so that's that's an example
of using the couplet API against against
the cluster the other example
specifically a Shopify was using the
coop and so you can see there's a bunch
of stuff here not all of it immediately
decipherable but eventually the bug
report includes fact that there's a key
and a certificate that can they use for
TLS bootstrapping with the couplet this
is another thing where gk has the
countermeasure but it wasn't enabled so
there's a feature called metadata
concealment and there long term plans to
distribute closer metadata more securely
but you just need to opt in to that kind
of concealment to stop this kind of
attack you can see on the Left we're
monitoring for things like cloud
metadata access so this container ended
up contacting the cloud metadata server
and that is not in it's sort of normal
behavior and so we've alerted I'm gonna
move on now to the echo fected I'll
highlight this is inspired by but it's
not an exact reproduction I don't think
they're using thinners I don't think
they were using GK but it's an example
of where application vulnerabilities
really can hit you even though you're in
containers containers have all these
rich configuration options
running as different users running with
read only route FS abstracting away the
access to secret things abstracting
storage away from you but you can still
write an app that gives people access
and have not configured the security
boundaries well enough that they they
can keep going okay so I'm gonna deploy
a applet is vulnerable to a struts CVE
that allows remote command execution so
that's created and I've created a
sensitive database service that all then
contact so I'm going to go ahead and
just make a crafted HTTP requests that
injects the command and connects to that
database and dump some information about
it the databases the table is inside so
the port forward is still gonna do this
live so we're gonna pull the info the
pods okay now I'm gonna start again okay
so you can see the data leak here so
we're able to make this large exciting
crafted HTTP request that included some
my sequel commands and then the output
was all the databases in the database
and then all the tables and if there
were more and more stuff in there you
could have executed commands like that
also you can see in the left hand side
we've alerted on a lateral movement
because these services don't typically
talk in this manner so just an example
of runtime monitoring of those
connectivity graphs and to catch the
lateral movement once they've gotten in
on the initial foothold they're trying
to get the objective so trying to get
through your data they're trying to get
the things that they want alright so I'm
gonna hand it back to Allen after this
I'm excited to have shown you three
real-world real-world scenarios in a GK
environment and the way that both GK
defaults and stack rush tie protection
can help secure your workloads thanks
so call-to-action we covered a lot of
topics today and there's a whole bunch
of sessions that are going on next that
go really deep into various areas
yesterday there's actually a great
session one of our PM's delivered around
kubernetes and enterprise security
requirements all going to be available
on YouTube and then today there's a
bunch of sessions one on containers and
kubernetes engine that really goes deep
into some of the differentiators with
google kubernetes engine and then later
on the afternoon there's a session on
best practices from Google I sorry I
highly recommend checking that out it's
going to be really a combination of both
gke and sto and then there's a session
later in the afternoon really around you
know running managed kubernetes both in
a gke perspective but from a multi cloud
standpoint so for those of you that were
in the keynote yesterday you probably
heard the announcement around gke and
the on-prem component so it's going to
get really interesting in terms of you
know providing that consistent
experience for managing your
applications in a hybrid fashion so with
that thank you very much for your time
really appreciate it and I wanted to
thank the speakers way Alex and Connor
very nicely done
we'll take a few questions so if you do
have questions please walk over to the
podium and an ask away thank you
[Music]